My name is Sir Mohammed Anwar Pervez, OBE.
I'd like to show you a letter which I received from Margaret Thatcher.
She was not the Prime Minister at that time, but she wrote me a message:...
..."Sir Anwar Pervez OBE, may I add my own congratulation to those of your many other friends and admirers..."
"...as you celebrate the award of your knighthood from Her Majesty, the Queen."
I'm very proud of it because, you know, she more or less has my frame of mind.
Although she is known to be a very tough lady, but in her mind and heart the community and people are very important for her.
And so I feel the same way.
I opened my first Cash & Carry in 1976.
From one shop, now we have 51 wholesale warehouses in the UK with nearly one hundred thousand square feet in each depot.
Four and a half thousand people are working quite quickly.
Turnover is over two billion.
But I don't feel we are big.
In the UK, I became very successful...
...and for Pakistani listeners I'll say that the secret of this country is that no matter what color you are, what nationality you are,...
...you are treated as a human being. Indian, Pakistani, West Indian, wherever you are from.
If you are on this soil, you have equal opportunity for everybody.